reject nation it is time for more koi's comic
corner i am very excited to be joining you
guys today we're going to be talking about dc's
upcoming slate but first i want to remind you to
leave a like those help me out to keep this show
going also comment subscribe hit that bell so you
get notified of all these shows coming at you
and again thank you for being so supportive of
koi's comic corner i am honored to be here let's
talk about dc slate now usually i give you guys
a breakdown of where we are with dc or where we
are with this comic property or where the rumors
are or what comics to read etc that's what i like
this channel corner to be about but in this case i
want to go a little different and just give you
an onslaught of information and then just give
you some general dc comic recommendations at the
end i'm going to give you 20 different movies in
various stages of development these are the top 20
either in development fully made post-production
or rumored properties coming out of dc films
because i want to see in a year or two which one
of these actually came to pass i think it's gonna
be really interesting with all of the shake-ups
over at dc because of the big big discovery merger
a lot of the big higher-ups are getting shaken
up a lot of the movies that were almost happening
have been canceled a lot of things might get green
lit but i think it'll be really interesting
to look back at this video in a year or two
and see what actually came to pass some of these
we obviously know are coming out obviously black
adam etc we'll get into that but first let's dive
into the giant slate of maybe movies over at dc
first one i want to talk about just got confirmed
with a title that is joker 2 volley i'm not french
even though my last name is i'm sorry to every
french-speaking person for that pronunciation this
means the madness of two joker to the madness of
two i think that it's gonna be really cool to play
with the mythology outside of the world of batman
some more because we saw a young bruce wayne
in joker i never personally my opinion want to
see joaquin's joker go up against a batman i think
it's much more interesting to have that lived
separately i personally want robert pattinson to
have his barry keon i want to see other batmans
have their jokers but i like joaquin phoenix's
joker being over there having an else world living
in that world hey guys koi's out of town otherwise
i'd have him do the pickup here himself but he
actually did a joker video talking about the whole
lady gaga casting here that's going to be a
musical we shot this before that news broke but
yeah cut out a lot of other stuff he was
speculated on here but you can go check that
one out we got the flash movie up next i don't
think a movie has ever had more of a struggle
with a single individual ever i mean there are
obviously people that mess up in life and they're
obviously asterixes and yes things have been more
problematic there are directors that have done
horrible things they're actors that have done
horrible things there are people that are bad
but i don't know if the consistency has been hit
i know it must be a struggle for the fine folks
at wb to be navigating the news cycles and i
really hope ezra miller can navigate what he's
going through i really hope that they find what
peace they can when they can that said it's been
like a monthly news cycle situation so i don't
know what dc and warner brothers can do with the
flash because by the time it comes out we keep
hearing more and more things we keep hearing
rumors that the maybe adding in a post-credits
scene maybe recasting via flashpoint it is very
expensive to recast it is very tricky to this late
in the game change things and i personally i don't
know ezra i want ezra to find what solace he can
and and clearly there's some lashing out happening
so for the sake of the film i'm very excited
to see michael keaton back as batman i'm very
excited to see flashpoint i'm very excited for
the surprises i'm very excited as a batfleck fan
to get to say bye to batfleck i love ben affleck's
portrayal as batman i really truly i'll take any
frame of flex batman in a movie so i'm excited
for this film but on the more human real elements
i don't know how they're going to promote it i
don't know how they're going to end it i don't
know how they're going to continue that story on
and i want the human that is ezra to get the help
they need and i want the studio that is warner
brothers to find a compromise to have this movie
come out because i really want to see it we'll see
what happens in between there next up we've got
blue beetle this is really high on my list because
it looks incredible from leaked photos i do not
talk about paparazzi photos it's a rule of mine i
do not believe in them because frankly seeing an
unfit it's like you go into a a museum and there's
a pencil drawing that's not fair to compare to
this beautiful lush monet a finished product is
what you should experience that is presented to
you if you see a leaked shot of a costume usually
it needs the augmentation of post-production
usually it needs a little zhu xin up with some cgi
because comics aren't real i know for me to say
that is sacrilege but rarely do i see a comic book
costume that looks like it was ripped off the page
in a paparazzi photo leaked image as the blue
beetle suit came out and i am gobsmacked this
looks incredible i've seen nothing official and
i am so overjoyed at how incredible it looks
and homeboy from karate kid is awesome so the
casting's great the look is great blue beetle's a
really fun character hope we get a little booster
gold action i think zac efron might be a little
old for human torch at this point depending on
how young they go because he's friends of tomahawk
spider-man i digress he'd be a great booster
gold give me zac efron's booster gold in the
blue beetle movie even as a cameo very excited for
blue beetle and very quickly blue beetle is a very
industrious for hire at times superhero that's
often down on his luck that navigates the world
opposite booster gold who is a very very social
media inherent uh superhero so blue beetle's got
money booster gold needs attention and they
team up very often the comics offering a very
different dynamic duo situation so booster
gold is not confirmed but it's kind of like
if you make a robin movie you expect batman not
to belittle blue beetle but they they kind of go
together all right next up we've got aquaman and
the lost kingdom this is high because i don't know
how you make a sequel to a movie with an octopus
playing drums i don't know how you go crazier and
inherently sequels get crazier inherently you
have escalation i personally like the aquaman
movie i got it made a billion dollars so a lot of
other people did too is it the comics absolutely
not is it a blast absolutely do i want a sequel
yes what is it i don't know will it have amber
herd in it maybe but i am however getting reports
in my lack of earbud ear they did talk about it
at the trial at some point and now walter hamada
did say it was a buddy movie between patrick
wilson and jason momoa and that's about the main
headline i got out of that craziness so we do
have a little bit of taste and tone of what that
movie's gonna be and you guys know i love a buddy
movie so aquaman is a buddy movie give me that all
right next up we've got black adam this is a movie
i think that's gonna combine the strengths of the
rox properties and the strengths of dc universe's
scope i do think that it's going to be a very rock
centric movie we just got the first trailer it
looks like a rock movie there's a certain kind of
humor and action and levity the rock brings to his
properties we know how hands on he is we know that
seven bucks productions is very very much a part
of the script a part of the edit a part of the
whole journey so i think we're gonna see the most
rock movie possible within the dc universe and
that's gonna be interesting because i think dc
is doing a very good job at diversifying
their content i think a shared universe works
and it doesn't have to i like the marvel cinematic
universe but there are times that i imagine people
are exhausted them like i have to watch a six-hour
show i've got to watch a three-hour movie you
don't have to do that with dc you can just watch
these movies so i think it's really important
especially with black adam that people that are
fans of the rock don't necessarily have to watch
everything dc's doing i think that people that are
fans of the dc universe they don't have to watch
every single property coming out it's a win-win i
think this movie is going to make a lot of money
i think the rock is dedicated he 11 years in
pre-production hell really excited for this
one if only because of the sheer zeal coming out
of the rock we'll see what it actually translates
to and that's coming up soon that was your top
five i realize i've already talked way too long
so we're gonna speed up here with six through
twenty number six we got shazam fury of the gods
this is coming out very soon it is a sequel to the
first shazam i think my favorite dc property of
all i love that first movie this is gonna have the
kids growing up we actually have mary marvel being
herself as both iterations of marvel so clearly
aging is an element and i love the tone the
amblin toad that david f sandberg was able to
accomplish can't wait to see the sequel then
we've also got the superman reboot coming from
jj abrams now this is interesting because i've
heard we're getting a valzod series from michael
b jordan and it's rumored that we're gonna have a
black clark kent in this superman reboot so i'm
curious to see which these properties comes out
first how they might interact with each other i
know that jj is not directing it i believe it's uh
not tom hassie coates that's gonna be handling
the directing duties i love jj as a producer
i'm really curious especially because he was
attached to a superman flyby property that
was supposed to come out way before the brandon
rothman did so i know he loves superman excited
for that property and to see how it develops we've
also got a batgirl property which is going to be
originally set for hbo max that is now going to
theaters there was so much uproar about it being
an hbo max release that it actually got bumped
up to a theatrical release more of that i love
my theatrical releases and i love the character
of batgirl very curious to see barbara gordon
and we do have jk simmons reprising his role as
commissioner gordon which means it is somewhat
tied into the universe but it does come out after
flashpoint just like we had the great jk simmons
has j jonah jameson in no way home he seemed to
be a different jj jameson in no way home than the
original we might have that with commissioner
gordon but we also have the little fact that
michael keaton is in this as well does it tie into
the tim burton universe post flashpoint is it a
batman beyond kind of vibe where he is a
mentor very curious to see how this translates
really excited for this batgirl movie we've also
got wonder woman three this is presumably from
patty jenkins i am a giant giant proponent for the
first one it's my number two dc property i think
after shazam right before the suicide squad huge
wonder woman fan i really want them to get back in
that like beautiful magical overwhelming scope
of the first and i think they will i think dc
smart they're going to take some notes about what
didn't work in the second and give us a huge third
and at number 10 we've got the batman 2. this is
something i want to do an entire video about so
if you're a fan of koi's comic corner let me know
that's something you want to see i've got an idea
of what the entire trilogy yes the batman 3 is
rumored how i would shape it what i would do but
as of now we are confirmed for a the batman 2 i
think it might be mr freeze i think it also might
have some setup for the court of owls which ends
up being the third movie but again i'm gonna make
a whole video about that we've also got zatanna
this is the one that i'm most worried about that
i'm also most excited for so if those top 10 were
my most anticipated this is the one where i'm like
all right now we're getting into the does this
exist territory which is fitting for the second
half of this list zatanna is a magician she is
awesome she has magic powers technically she can
take out superman because homeboy can't handle
magic she's a very interesting character she's
got a really iconic look and she's often written
incredibly fun she's very very captivating and
often a member of the dark justice league so
please have zaton exist i want it my next most
anticipated in the i don't know if it'll happen
is nightwing this movie has been in development
forever it has had the same director attached for
as long as i can remember and i do believe this
is the thing that would expand out the batman
universe without needing the batman i think you
can much easier make a nightwing movie without
batman than say a robin movie or even a batgirl
movie i think you can make a nightwing movie and
have dick grayson fully formed and in bloodhaven
give me that nightwing movie next up we've got
static shock this is our 13th property static
shock has been in development for a few years but
got some heat at dc fandom when it was confirmed
they announced a writer they announced a team i
keep hearing michael b jordan might be involved
as producer i can't get confirmation on that but
i do think this is something that hbo max could
use i want it to be theatrical but i love that
90s animated series it's a comic book that's
really important it's a comic book that addresses
more street level things it's a comic book that
addresses interpersonal relationships much like
spider-man does and i love the actual character
of static himself and i think they could do some
really cool things playing with tone and i think
it's a really special property static shock is
a really cool character that has electric-based
powers but he uses them in more ingenuity based
ways so he's got like a disc right and he can fly
around on it because of static electricity so he
wields it not like electro directly he actually
you know he can zap people but he also uses it to
fly he also uses it to power certain things it's
a really almost stem based idea where it's using
electricity in inventive and science-based ways
instead of the more traditional zap zap we've also
got black canary this has been development for
quite some time she is the on and off again love
interest of green arrow she's a character that is
very hard to translate correctly but i think if
you do it right is a very empowering character
she is a fascinating take on a lot of uh strong
feminist ideals that i think if they land will
really empower a lot of people and i think that
her costume is inherently empowering if you do it
right so as much as i want to see a lot of these
other characters i'd love to see black canary
handled deftly because she's really funny she's
really intimidating at the right times in all the
right ways next up we have supergirl speaking of
characters i'd love to see to get time to shine
in a full feature-length film this is a character
i've actually struggled with this is a character
who doesn't always work in the comics for me this
is a character that when written poorly feels like
hey what if superman was a girl but when they
write her correctly she's the cousin of kellell
that has her own journey that's been through
her own struggles that has a lot of different
issues with her powers that i personally
recently love the tom king run there's a
supergirl woman of tomorrow series that one that's
a great just title it's a play on man of tomorrow
but also like supergirl into woman woman tomorrow
her evolution her journey from a supergirl to a
superwoman all of that's great but supergirl is a
character that is really hard to find the pathos
in that's really hard to find the connection to if
she's not written well tom king's run connected me
to her in a way that i hadn't been before so i
highly recommend that run and i really hope that
the supergirl movie can feel the same and i want
little girls to have a character to look up to i
mean there's so many beautiful female-led stories
i've already mentioned here but i really want dc
fans not just have wonder woman i want little
girls to not just have these characters that
they're like oh this character feels like me and
i think supergirl can do that for a lot of people
we've also got the untitled man of steel sequel i
hope it exists i want it i need it will it happen
will henry cavill get to put on the suit that he
has in his closet ever again i hope so this is low
on the list because i don't know if it'll ever
happen i want to believe it'll happen it's the
one i could use the most give me man of steel too
henry cavill is superman let him fly lobo i love
i love the character lobo number 17 lobo this
man is dc's answer to deadpool this man fights
santa claus this man has so many weird space
hijinks imagine a space pirate deadpool imagine
captain jack sparrow but he's jacked and he
talks like basically jason mamoa would have been
perfectly cast if he wasn't aquaman i want that
kind of rough and tumble biker from space he's
got a giant space hog and flies around thieving
pillaging he's an anti-hero that actually feels
like an anti-hero but he's written really fun and
like i said he fights santa claus from time to
time that's how little beeps he gives i don't know
if we swear yet in koi's comic corner i digress
next up black hawk this is the first of two that i
don't think will ever exist this was a movie that
steven spielberg was attached to i had the middle
section that was maybes with a side of doubt now
that we're past man of steel stronger doubt next
up we've got one that was just canceled it could
get revived though since it was just cancelled
at the top of the discovery merger depending how
far along they were i could see it coming back it
is the wonder twins movie the wonder twins are an
iconic duo from the super friends era and you know
the people that they do like handsman they turn
into ones water ones an animal they're crazy but i
think it could work for a younger audience i think
depending on how well dc super pets does i could
see wonder twins being revived and i do think we
need to also appeal to a younger audience joker
very dark and adult birds of prey very dark and
adult the batman very dark and adult we do have
shazam which is you know about kids but there's
crazy demons that eat people and throw them out of
buildings i think there could be some things that
are geared towards towards kids and i think wonder
tone to be a great one and finally my number 20 of
any dc character next to mr miracle which i don't
know if i'll ever get but i really really wanted
we were supposed to get a property from avery to
verne and tom king but i really wanted to happen
i don't think it ever will called new gods next
to mr miracle the comic character i want plastic
man plastic man officially as a writer i don't
know if that means development is further along
or if they've just accepted one of the scripts but
plastic man recently got some movement and it is
officially technically on the dc slate and those
are 20 dc properties i hope we get and this was
hopefully under 20 minutes it has been humbling
to be here on rejects channel without the og real
rejects because i'm considering myself one
now i just said oh geeks i'm the new blood
koi's comic's corner is because of folks like you
i got so many comments talking about wanting me
to have my own thing here and then the first video
did so well i'm honored to be here with more stuff
this was a different format so if you guys also
like these mega lists leave a comment below let
me know it works i also hope some of these comic
recommendations i gave you if you want any of
these characters specific comic runs i couldn't
i gave you 20. i couldn't give you each one
but if there's anyone you specifically want to
know leave a comment if there's any video you want
from this list of 20 where i can extrapolate in
the usual format out let me know and if you want
any questions answered directly you can find me on
tik tok you can leave a comment here below you can
find me on twitter hunt me down on the internet
i want to share my comic zeal with you and that's
we're doing right here i appreciate y'all
we'll see you next time on koi's comic corner